la bataille est née de la sphère dit d
in plant files en 2018 le journal le
monde ainsi que 58 autres médias on
travaillait sur une enquête portant sur
les implants médicaux dans le cadre du
consortium international des
journalistes d'investigation le travail
de 250 journalistes de 36 pays a permis
de révéler un manque de contrôle par les
autorités sanitaires lorsque des
dispositifs médicaux sont mis sur le
marché en france la journaliste du monde
chargé de cette enquête s'adresse alors
au laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essais l'organisme français de
certification des dispositifs médicaux
son but obtenir la liste des dispositifs
labellisé cee conformité européenne et
non labellisés devant le refus opposé
par cet établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial
la journaliste saisit alors la scea des
as qui répondra par la négative le 25
octobre 2018 après la publication des
premières séries d'articles sur les
implants price
la scea des as dont on parle ici c'est
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs
elles contrôlent l'accès des
particuliers à ces derniers ici la cda a
justifié son refus en invoquant la
fameuse loi sur le secret des affaires
la commission considère toutefois que la
communication de la liste des
dispositifs médicaux auxquels la société
gmd a délivré le marquage ce et eux
visés au point un serait susceptible de
porter atteinte au secret des affaires
protégé par le premier alinéa de
l'article l 311 tirer 6 du code des
relations entre le public et
l'administration en révélant des
informations économiques sur cette
entreprise à savoir le nom des
fabricants de ces dispositifs avec
lesquels la société gm ed a contracté la
commission émet donc un avis défavorable
cette loi promulguée en juillet 2018
avait provoqué de nombreuses inquiétudes
parmi les ong mais aussi chez les
journalistes et les lanceurs d'alerté
voici par exemple ce qu'en dit
l'association anticor la définition des
secrets d'affaires est si vaste que
n'importe quelle information interne à
une entreprise peut désormais être
classés dans cette catégorie
l'infraction au secret des affaires
aurait lieu dès lors que ces
informations seraient obtenus
ou diffuser et leur divulgation seraient
passibles de sanctions pénales
les dérogations institué par le texte
sont trop faible pour garantir
l'exercice des libertés fondamentales
c'est là le pouvoir de cette loi devenir
une arme de dissuasion massive une arme
de dissuasion massive pour reprendre les
mots d'anticorps contre laquelle le
monde et une trentaine d'organisations
ont décidé de se battre
un recours a été déposé au tribunal
administratif de paris
l'audience s'est tenue le 1er octobre et
selon nos informations le verdict de ce
dernier est attendu dans une quinzaine
de jours